And the answer is, it'll be Black Discerning Mortimer. So, there's a lot of
interesting and somewhat surprising stuff going on here. So, I hope when you
solve this, if you did it by an experiment, you tried to find a general rule
instead of just seeing what the result was. If you didn't do that yet, try it
now, see if you can figure out a general rule for why we end up with this
result. Then, come back for the explanation, which will follow. So, here's
what's going on here. So, we have this class hierarchy. And when we have
multiple base classes the order in which they're listed matters. So, we listed
Discerning Bear first. That means, the Discerning Black Bear will inherit the
init method from Discerning Bear. What happens in the init method of Discerning
Bear is we call super, passing in Discerning Bear. That means, ignoring
definition of super bear and calling init. Looking just at this part, you would
think, well, that means we're going to call the Bear init method. And that's
what would normally happen, if we just started with a Discerning Bear. That's
not what happens, though. What we get when we have super (DiscerningBear, self),
well, remember the first class we passed in her means ignore that class. But the
next class in the hierarchy, if we look at this, is actually what we got here.
The super, here, we'll call the init method for the BlackBear. Now the super of
the self object for the BlackBear, now is going to be Bear, and we'll get to the
Bear init. So, this is kind of surprising. This is one of the dangers of using
multiple inheritence that it becomes pretty tricky to understand what some code
means.